set up an execution the governor was
hoping to Grant those inmates life
without parole but families of the
victims as well as several District
Attorneys successfully sued Joshua
piguero Joins us live in studio after
hearing from some of these families
Joshua now the families were upset with
State officials who they say tried to
railroad through a proposal to commune
sentences Governor sicilight took time
to address the issue at the Board of
Pardons saying his action was attended
as an act of Grace
as structured the system does not work
that is clear to me the state has not
carried out an execution since 2006.
that means that families of the victims
are held in limbo last week outgoing
Governor Cicely got an agenda item added
to the Board of Pardons meeting which
meets quarterly it would have commuted
death sentences of all current 57
inmates the Board of Pardons serves a
unique purpose based on the principles
of mercy and decency granting clemency
is an act of Grace but families of loved
ones murdered by death row inmates were
not on board I spoke to Tehran Bolden
last week his brother was killed by Omar
Harris in 2013. he let the governor know
how he felt it was a stab in the face
and a slap and I am extremely hurt
I have not been able to sleep Kenny
Cherry also lost his life by Harris he
shot Cherry as he was driving on the
Strip that shooting triggered a crash
that led to two other deaths including
Bolden Cherry's father says Harris has
to be killed for his family to get
closure they want to give this guy
a second chance
you need to give my son a second chance
he also criticized sisalak for not
Consulting families I hope this new
governor so I found his team up and
start doing whatever needs to be done so
I can come down and witness this guy who
killed my son watch him die
in his decision the Carson City judge
said the pardons board failed to
properly notify the families of the
victims 15 days before the meeting some
of the family who spoke today say they
were only given a few days to prepare a
Christian